here with reaction former white house
chief of staff reince priebus Texas
Congressman Ronnie Jackson welcome both
of you Congressman I'll begin with you
tonight
this has been a bombshell week when I
say quoting John Dean a cancerous
surrounding a malignant one around the
the presidency of Joe Biden Am I Wrong
am I overstating that fact
you're not overstating that at all Sean
and the evidence is just building
exponentially if you look at all the
stuff that's out there right now it is
absolutely unbelievable how much stuff
is out there the picture has been fully
painted we know what's going on here and
I I I find encouraging that we have
aggressive members in these committees
that are looking into this an aggressive
chairman on oversight and Judiciary and
ways in Maine so looking into a variety
of issues all paths lead back to Joe
Biden via Hunter Biden every single one
of them and the Biden family and all the
payoffs they've got this is this is
getting out of control I'm telling you
right now uh that uh it's gonna get it's
going to get tougher and tougher to get
information initially but it's the dam
is going to break because I think that
they're going to be a lot of FBI agents
and other you know people in doj and
that are going to be implicated that are
going to be drawn into this they've so
aggressively covered up for the Biden
family and their criminal activities
that they're going to be also criminally
liable for some of the stuff that's
going on here so they're going to have
their own uh incentive now to to cover
this stuff up but what I will tell you
you is that documents are going to
continue to leak out whistleblowers are
going to continue to come forward and I
promise you I'll just put this out as a
member of Congress that if you're part
of the problem if you're within one of
these organizations and you know what's
going on come forward tell us what's
happening because we will get to the
truth we will find out eventually and
it's better for us to find out via these
whistleblowers and some of the people
within our organization telling us then
for us to have to find them because it's
you know the cover-up is always worse
than the crime and that's what we're
going to see here all the crimes pretty
are pretty horrendous here reince
prievous let me ask you this uh This
Confidential informant for the FBI
speaking with the head of barisma after
Biden first talked about the corruption
of the prosecutor he forced to be fired
Victor shoken uh the guy's name is
mccola Zola chevski he he actually
answering the question uh about Victor
shokun and and asked about the
investigation into Barista he just
replied something to the effect oh don't
worry Hunter will take care of all these
issues through his dad and the informant
you know goes further suggesting that
Zola chesky hires some attorney for
fifty thousand to litigate the case and
he goes well it costs 5 million to pay
one Biden and 5 million to pay another
Biden and then it's making the comment
uh that it was the money was was buried
so deeply it would take 10 years to find
the records pretty damn reince priebus
and we've covered a lot of corruption
over the years on this show
well you laid it out masterfully and you
know Congressman Jackson as well look
the Chuck Grassley said that there were
tapes and what will be very interesting
is the connectivity between this
allegation and Joe Biden we know that we
we you laid it out but if if there is
indeed tapes and conversations with Joe
Biden's name on it that's the kind of
connectivity that gets to The Ballot Box
that's the connection that it that that
equals the corruption and the minds of
those independent voters that are out
there in Wisconsin Pennsylvania and
Michigan that that can make a big
difference Joe Biden had a terrible week
this week he couldn't get his message
straight on bidenomics whatever that is
his polling is still upside down with
recent polling showing 67 percent of the
American people say that we're on the
wrong track and the economy is the
number one issue while he's out there
spouting about bidenomics they've got
Cornell West who's well known running as
a green Party candidate they've got a No
Labels flirtation so they've got three
entities swimming in the same Democrat
Pond and on top of it all you laid out
what could be a growing cancer that if
this connectivity is there with his
voice is it's been alleged now
who knows where this thing's going to go
Sean all right thank you both uh we
appreciate it hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else